foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's new webinar
titled commercialization and
entrepreneurial lessons from
microfluidic biotechnology startups this
webinar is part of the sixth annual
laboratory automation virtual event and
I'm Susie Valdez of Labyrinth and I will
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labroots so let's get
started
before we begin I want to remind
everyone that this event
we encourage you to First participate by
communicating with other attendees using
our new live chat feature during the
presentation you can find that live chat
located on the right of your screen you
can also participate by submitting as
many questions as you want during this
presentation
to do so quickly type them into the ask
a question box and click Send we'll
answer as many questions as we have time
for at the end of this presentation now
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation just click on
that help desk located at the bottom of
your screen within the navigation bar or
from the lobby and finally as a reminder
this presentation is educational and
offers free continuing education credits
click on the continuing education
credits link located in the abstract
window below the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits without further Ado I now
present today's speaker Dr Kalyan handiq
vice president and Advanced Technologies
at biorad for the complete biography of
our speakers please visit the biography
tab at the left of your screen Dr handy
welcome we may now begin your
presentation sir
thank you Susie
good morning good afternoon or good
evening depending on where you are
thank you for joining this webinar and
then thanks to lab roots for allowing me
to present this keynote speech
again that the the topic of my you know
talk today is really going through the
commercialization and the lessons
learned through two of the biotech
startups and 11 cell C
please uh you know type as many
questions as you can and try to answer
as as best as I can during the one hour
talk and you know q a session if need be
I will have uh Suzy collate those
questions and then we'll see if we can
the ones that I'm not able to answer
because of time will try to get to them
uh you know later somehow
so um again I am based in Ann Arbor
Michigan
and then uh you know I before I go
through my startup Journey just to give
you a little bit of background on my my
career Journey so I got got my PhD in
chemical engineering at University of
Michigan
95 to 2000
I was fortunate to have worked in a
highly interdisciplinary team you know I
was part of the chemical engineering but
I worked with electrical engineers and
human genetics department so from the
get-go I got a very very exciting
interdisciplinary environment and we we
had a really uh you know a nice uh you
know team environment trying to build
something very very unique
and as a result of you know some of the
you know collaborative work at Michigan
we were uh you know we built a DNA
analysis chip I'll go through it uh
later in the beginning of my uh talk
about handy lab
after my PhD I started a company called
handy lab
it focused on automated DNA and all
analyzers for hospitals primarily
focused on infectious disease
the company was acquired by BD in 2009
and and then I stayed on with BD for
about a year and a half
after that I joined another startup in
Ann Arbor it used to be called the novo
sciences and it changed the name to cell
C
I joined that company in 2011 and then
the company got acquired by biorad in in
April of 2020.
I'm still with biored so you know
between between the two startups you
know it it has taken up most of my last
22 years of my of my career and I had an
exciting time really starting these two
companies going through the entire
process of you know ups and downs of
this journey of taking a product concept
all the way to you know products that
are commercialized and that really made
an impact to the either the clinical
Diagnostics Market or the life science
Market
let me start with a little bit of story
about handy lab again uh I will try to
narrate it from how I saw it you know
different uh people that went to the
company would have uh in a different
experience but this is purely you know
how I saw it having started it right
from the beginning and stay true till
the end
so how did handilap start so as I
mentioned I was at University of
Michigan a PhD student got a very
exciting team to work on a DNA
sequencing chip
so we were fortunate to have uh you know
the right environment to build something
very unique so we created a DNA analysis
chip in 1998
it was one of the breakthroughs in that
year so it was the first chip that could
take small amounts of DNA mix it with
different enzymes go through different
uh you know enzymatic reactions whether
restriction digestion or some
amplification
and load a Micro gel electrophoretic
Channel
go through the separation of the DNA
bands and then detect all the product in
the same chip it's a highly integrated
chip that allowed a lot of things to be
done from DNA into results out so it was
pretty unique and that really put
University of Michigan the group that
I'm working on in the map in the
scientific community in fact this chip
is in the Smithsonian right now
so you know it was very exciting to work
on that but you know having worked on a
very fast pace you know research kind of
environment I really wanted this kind of
work to really get to the customer you
know make it into a product that people
can use and say hey this is really
beneficial for our work and that kind of
prompted me to really look into the
startup area because when I was you know
doing my PhD I often saw the best work
was always coming out of the startups
and long story short I got connected to
some local investors who really were
interested in helping commercialize this
technology out of University of Michigan
and then I reached out back to my group
and I had another colleague in the PHD
team sundares brahmasandro so we teamed
up and then we started handy lab in 2000
and the vision was really a handle
laboratory you know it's a handle device
that you would have a disposable
cartridge that can analyze DNA
and then through the tech transfer we
got access to couple of patents mostly
related to in a Micro World technology
in fact it is the you know uh the same
thing that I worked on my P is a thesis
so I was pretty familiar with it
so it it looked pretty good and then you
know we we had you know this vision and
we were able to get excitement among the
investors locally and they put in money
but little did we know that it's not an
easy ride you know what we did at the
University and what when we started
looking into what really needed to be
done
to pick the right application it took us
a while and then also figuring out how
to tailor this technology to a
particular application so we started
looking into the Infectious Disease
because you had the Need for Speed
and then we soon realized that our
technology was not complete I mean we we
could analyze DNA get results and then
you know when we really started digging
into details of how to apply it to a
specific you know clinical sample in in
this first case we picked up uh you know
something related to you know Group B
strap detection in pregnant mom
and we try to you know really figure out
how to do the sample prep it took us
additional development on the sample
prep technology
the other thing that we did was you know
when we took the technology from news
Michigan and really started digging into
the cost analysis how much it would cost
to build a complete disposable we
realized that the microfabricated glass
silicon process that we had you know
done at University was not gonna meet
the cost needs so we had to Pivot to
injection molded you know technology we
also moved the sensors the heaters and
all the things that are required for the
actuation move it from the Disposable to
the instrument
and then we I will talk more about you
know microvials later on you know we had
used wax as a way to you know move uh a
plug of x to block channels we adopted
uh nanoliters solder dispensing for you
know the wax valve creation
we also had to create a lot of sample
Technologies to uh kind of you know meet
the needs of the you know the clinical
sample and then you know and then also
we had to lifelize the reagents whether
for the PCR or the sample prep and also
figure out how to store liquid reagents
in the cartridge in blisters
so long story short we it took us
another five years to really put it all
together so we we did build it a
complete integrated cartridge that had
liquid reagents dried reagents and then
it had all the fluidic network to
connect all the different components
required for sample prep to asset prep
and then real-time PCR along with the
controls we moved all the critical
sensors to the instrument
and then you know it's a really nice
embodiment of a lab on the chip
technology that that you know we all
dreamed about
and then you know that that was not easy
it took us another 20 million over that
five years you know luckily we kept
innovating through the process so we we
were able to secure funding uh from The
Venture capitalists along the way but it
did come with a lot of board changes a
lot of leadership changes but you know
the the technical team had the tenacity
to really pull it off and then you know
it really made you know we're we're
proud of these uh achievements uh by I
think it was about 2006. uh we really
had a true lab on a chip and we we
started to uh focus on the clinical
trial for the first application we met
with FDA we we had our uh in our
pre-clinical testing and we had lined up
uh in a couple of hospitals to do uh the
clinical sample testing and compare it
to other other you know methods
so you know there I'll just go through
some of the details you know the the lab
on a chip cartridge had uh in a large
sample chamber where you can you know
put in a swap system and up to about one
milliliters you could mix reagents uh in
it you could heat it up to the enzymatic
license and then it also had the nucleic
acid capture magnetic beads or you know
in this case you know in this embodiment
we use the size certain size you know
particles with the affinity for nucleic
acid and you could concentrate all these
beads into a very small inline filter uh
just about two millimeter diameter and
then when you wash through all the junk
and then you elude the nucleic acid you
could concentrate them down to one
microliters starting out from a one ml
uh sample so in a huge level of
concentration and you're also removing
all the junk and then you know you would
have uh storage for the waste that comes
out of it
so any lab on a chip uh
operation you need a lot of
okay so you you need a lot of uh fluidic
uh steps to be able to meter nanolitter
amounts of you know reagents mix it with
the with the uh you know say nucleic
acid DNA
so you need specific times you want to
do this on in a microfluiding network so
we we used a wax that melts at precise
temperature those are pre-loaded in
certain parts of the fluidic network and
you could open it up by using a very
specifically designed uh in a micro
heater and then you could also use these
pumps that are part of the network with
you know materials in it that expands
you know to generate pressure uh to
create the pressure to move fluids
around so again in a very clever
utilization of different materials with
the fluidic network to make this work uh
through a instrument that had the
sensors and actuators built onto it we
could also close fluidic channels uh
when we need to block off parts of the
fluidic network either for some
additional you know operation or for
doing you know a high temperature
thermocycling protocols again we use wax
as a way to be you know melted locally
and then heat trapped air pocket behind
the wax to move the molten melted wax
and close close off Channel when needed
and then for for the liquid that needs
to be delivered at specific times we
created this blisters with a piercer
integrated and then something in the
instrument will push the blister down
the piercer will pierce a foil below the
liquid present in the blister you know
Will Will just flow through the fluidic
network and deliver it to wherever is
needed
so you know it's uh all come came
together in this small uh you know box
you know it's almost like a shoebox size
again it it was not a handle that we
wanted it need not be because that
particular result uh you know sample to
resolve took almost an hour
and then you know you you basically have
uh you know cartridge you just load the
sample put it in the instrument and
close it and then you get a result in an
hour
so again it's a nice this is you have to
think about it this is 2006 you know uh
it was pretty much you know we were able
to achieve uh you know something that we
all wanted you know put sample in and
get results uh you know in a certain
amount of time
but it was good but if you think about
in this this was in 2007 it was still
not good enough for what we needed to do
so the cost of the cartridge was still
high you know there were multiple layers
and then we would have needed additional
r d resource and design time to be able
to take out costs so I would say that
exercise would have taken another year
and a half or maybe two years at least
and the instrument could run only one
sample at a time so in a in a eight hour
shift you can do eight samples and then
if you look at the uh the cartridge
manufacturing there was a lot of
different components integrated so the
QC burden on manufacturing was also High
those could have been you know you know
reduce over time if you did another
design iteration
but you know uh even though we we made
the product you know we probably had uh
in the final design operation we had
over thousands of tests run either
mocked clinical samples or clinical
samples so you know it was definitely is
going to the rigor to make sure it
worked like it intended
but we still decided to stall the
product that was in 2007.
so we had a working point of care
product but if you think about it the
market was still not accepting point of
care molecular test at that time
it it is the not the case right now in
2022 I mean if you see there are lots of
point of care PCR tests for covet or
other respiratory virus right now in the
market again the other thing that we
probably needed to at that time was
reduce the time from that one hour down
to below half an hour maybe it would
have accepted you know by the market
but if you look back you know at that
time almost 100 percent of the nucleic
acid testing was done in large reference
Labs or big hospitals so the market had
still not moved to the hospitals or you
know other other testing sites
so you know we really thought that we
really need to focus the product to meet
the customer need at that point of time
and and the customer that we really
started to Target was the hospitals that
were trying to adopt molecular testing
so we had to you know re rethink how to
change the product to lower the cost of
goods make it higher throughput and also
make it more open instead of running a
fixed test we we wanted to give the
flexibility to the lab hospitals in the
hospitals to run their own PCR tests and
to do this we had to abandon microfilics
for the sample prep and embrace robotics
because that gave gave us the cost
Advantage uh for reducing the cost and
also improving the time
so you know think about that we've
already burned through about 30 million
in funding over six years and we went
back to the board and the investors
saying hey sorry our product didn't work
I mean it's not gonna generate the you
know revenues in the marketplace so you
know we need to reconfigure so you know
it was a Do or Die situation for the
company
and then we got one last chance to get
it right and that's what we did the next
18 months we built a product we call it
we used to call it Jaguar at that time
we launched it in 2008 and surprisingly
just like the covet pandemic now in 2008
uh the you know winter there was a H1N1
pandemic and when we built this product
and we you know started going out to the
you know trade shows and other uh
conferences it really started getting
picked up by the hospitals that really
wanted to bring in testing for H1N1 uh
you know flu and other things into the
hospitals and this was perfect because
the instrument could run 24 samples at
the same time it will give you results
in between two to three hours and then
it also had the flexibility to run a
variety of RNA assays or other DNA
assays as we were you know building the
the first few close FB assets on the
system
so this was you know also we kept the
the PCR in microfluidics
and the sample prep was uh you know
unitized in a raisin cartridge
so that everything was pre-stored uh
liquid reagents lifeless pellets as well
as the tips required for you know
running the instrument
so long story short you know the we we
really started selling this instrument
like hot cake and a lot of companies
wanted to partner with us including BD
Diagnostics they had uh they were
looking at putting Hospital Aqua
infection on a similar you know portable
Ben sub instrument and really liked the
the form fit and the performance so and
the the BD acquired the company in 2009
and then since then you know BD has done
a tremendous job of commercializing this
over the last uh you know 12 years uh
it's it's uh pulley it has placed
thousands and thousands of instruments
and tens of millions of cartridges in
fact when kovit uh really pandemic hit
in if you know 2020 and when you know
testing beca was off for kovid was uh
especially related to PCR was you know
becoming pointed Center BD uh BD Max was
one of the first to automate Kobe
testing so and it has served uh the the
world very well with with this
instrument and and the assets that can
be run on this system
so again uh I'd like to summarize with
one slide about the Journey of Handy lab
again it took us almost uh 10 years from
you know starting the company to getting
to a point where you know it got
acquired you know it was not easy you
know we we probably took the first uh
four or five years just to build up the
technology required to you know uh
satisfy the the key requirements for the
product
and then you know we along the way we we
are lucky to have got a variety of
funding either from VCS or Department of
Defense or you know ATP Grant and things
like that
but you know we really had to also pick
up the right people along the way you
know we also hired a CEO from the
diagnostic industry in 2004 that really
helped Focus the company into the right
product we build a point of care product
you know between uh 2004 uh through 2006
again
um it worked but still didn't meet the
needs of the market and then we had to
re-pivot the company to a more uh Ben
stop higher throughput system which is
now called the BD Max and that really
was was the right it was the right
product that the the market needed and
and then the rest was kind of uh history
so again you know uh I think getting
getting that right mix and pivoting at
the right time I think is very key for
us you know to be successful
so if I if I took uh the lessons from
handy lab these are the things that I
would summarize uh you know the key
ingredients for a startup success I
think the team and culture the initial
team need sets the cultural Innovation
you have to really innovate against the
incumbents and the other competitors in
the space to build value create IP but
as as you are you know building the
product you also have to bring in
commercial Focus theme to take it take
to build the right product and also grow
the company
the focus is also important as a you
know platform company you could go into
many different directions uh DNA
analysis could be used in infectious
disease pharmacogenomics you know
Veterinary testing how do we make sure
you're always focused on the right
application or set of applications uh to
to get the company focused because you
are startups do not have you know in
finite resources there's a set amount of
funding and time Horizon for you to get
it right
and then the right you know you have to
build the right product solving an unmet
need at that time you know getting that
you know juxtaposition of in a market
uh in our product and the channel fit I
think I think is very important and then
you know you you may have to Pivot along
the way to get to the right product and
and not having the company explode so
you know that that's very key and then
you do for for you know molecular
Diagnostics clinical Diagnostics because
of the uh you know the FDA uh
requirement the quality requirement the
rigor in testing uh you you really have
lots of a capital lead and then you know
that uh also you need need that Capital
to build a patent instead uh to protect
the company along the way
uh you need patience you know it's not
gonna come easy it in I've done two
startups each took away 10 years of my
life each time so you need the patience
and then again you know timing is key
getting the alignment of the the right
product the right market conditions and
also uh having a channel to get it out
to the marketplace
okay I'm gonna switch my focus to the
next startup cell C
this was a totally different story you
know with with handy lab we had
technology that came out of University
of Michigan that was uh you know being
developed for you know over five six
years before that but it's uh if a
completely different story for celsi
so celsi used to be called the novo
Sciences it was founded in 2010 by three
rookie biologists you know a priyagogue
uh sees a molecular biology student uh
Saida she's also a molecular biologist
and Chris simmer also had a
biotechnology degree
and they either met at school in the
master's program or met at another
startup uh you know Christian Priya met
at another you know uh drug Discovery
startup in Ann Arbor
and then uh you know the company was uh
focused on you know non-invasive cancer
diagnostics for a variety of reasons and
I was fortunate to have mentored the
theme you know it took almost every
almost a year to figure out the right
business plan where they could apply
their knowledge in biology in in in an
area of unmet needs so they actually won
the a business plan
into 2010 Great Lakes entrepreneurs
Quest only five thousand dollars but
that gave them enough confidence that
they got the business plan correct so
they can really start uh putting
together the technology around the
business plan
so I joined the company in 2011. again
you know it's a it's a new company with
lots of risk you know there is uh you
know they did have a good business plan
they have you know identified all the
nuances there were a lot of things uh
that need to be developed on the
technology uh raise money you know build
product so from my point of view uh I
was taking a huge risk but at the same
time I said okay let's let's give it a
shot for you know if I'm able to raise
money around the business plan you know
we will we will keep going at it
so I joined in August 2011 and within a
few months we were able to secure half a
million dollars by winning the world's
largest business plan competition it it
used to be called excellent Michigan so
the first prize was half a million
dollars so we're able to you know really
Garner that money and that really helped
you know fundraise for the company I was
able to secure Angel Investors from you
know uh investment for the company
and then we really started executing on
our technology and our plan based on get
after we got the money
so initially it was you know uh do
whatever it takes to generate data we we
created a you know microfluidic chip for
cancer cell isolation from blood and you
can see you know there's a uh uh slide
uh we call it DNA de novo chip below a
microscope and then we had tubing going
in to run blood through it you know we
used to call it internally Mr jankity
but it gave us enough data to you know
keep iterating on the on the product
that that we were uh planning to build
long story short it took us another uh
two years to have a minimal viable
product we had a chip we had a system
that could get that could run the
microfluidic chip with blood and here we
are focused on circulating tumor cell
um you know isolation and then you know
Downstream analysis and we also build a
platform to be able to do all the
different staining and other
post-processing uh and then we we
launched the product at ascr a
conference this was in DC and you can
see the early theme
and uh it was uh you know because of uh
my experience with handy lab we wanted
to make sure we were no matter what
we're always in sync with the market so
we kept going uh to the conferences to
get feedback make sure we're always
designing the right product so um
in
over the next few years we we generated
a lot of data in Partnerships with
variety of cancer institutes and other
you know biotech companies so we had uh
this this particular microfility chip we
we call it cell select so it's a it's
almost like a uh one inch by three inch
slide with a fluidic network that could
process you know whole blood directly
and you could run a blood at the rate of
one milliliter per minute and have even
though it's a fast flow it was able to
uh capture the cancer cells with very
high efficiency capture them in their
own uh you know chamber and then uh you
know have if you need you could remove
the cells out for Downstream culturing
or molecular analysis
and or you could also analyze the cells
in the slide using you know different
antibody stains
so we really uh allowed in a very rare
circulating tumor cells from blood to be
enriched and then the it was very very
promising technology and we also started
we met with FDA figured out the you know
what the clinical trial would look like
but that needed tens of millions of
dollars and another few years to go
through the clinical validation because
we have to go you know cancer by cancer
whether it's breast or prostate or you
know things like that and then you have
to you know go through the regulatory
approval so it it needed you know a lot
of funding for taking it through the
paces
so and as I tried raising money for this
uh in a product this was in 2015 2016.
it was there was very very it was very
difficult to raise money for another you
know circulating humor cell company even
though it had tremendous you know
advantages in cancer prognosis
monitoring and therapist selection the
funding was very tough at the time
there is there was a you know previous
device FDA approved device called cell
search that was already in the market
but it had poor performance
uh it missed uh circling tumor cells
because of the you know exact antibody
cocktail it used for capturing and that
really you know stunk up the market and
then uh in parallel there were a variety
of liquid biopsy companies based on Cell
free DNA enrichment that was Raising
billions of dollars the gardens the
Grails the foundation medicine and
things like that so that really you know
sucked up the money for it was not my
much money you know funding left for CTC
and we really had to figure out what to
do with the company
so we went back to the drawing board you
know we had IP that we had filed early
in 2011 on other single cell analysis
so we really pulled up you know other IP
and Technologies we had in in our you
know in the back burner and we started
focusing on a new area which is more in
the resource Market you know how to
uh capture you know you know hundreds of
thousands of cells in viable format at
the same time and allow an instrument to
be able to you know do a variety of
analysis on them and essentially it's a
it's a it's a resource Market called
single cell analysis we're trying to
parse out data from cell by cell level
and looks at you know millions of cells
at the same time
so we we realized this was a very
rapidly growing Market uh but it needed
you know you to be active very quickly
and you know in a delivery product so
this is what we did it's a Genesis
instrument
and then
over over the last next two years 2018
and 19 we really had to focus on the
Single Cell applications we invested
lots of uh you know dollars in product
developing protocols for single cell you
know capture single cell sequencing with
highlighting our uh you know increased
cell throughput increased cell viability
any and very streamlined Library prep
preparation steps
we increase the breadth of our patent
filings in single cell based on our
early priority date for our earlier
application so I remember in between
2018-19 we probably had you know 20 new
applications that we file really beefed
up our patent estate and then we also
brought in a really you know top-notch
uh commercial team from California into
Ann Arbor you know uh these are folks
that have that understood the the
sequencing market and also the Single
Cell analysis Market having worked at
other single cell uh companies like
fluidime uh John Stark became the CEO I
actually stepped down from the CEO role
uh Pat cook on operations uh Chad
Alexander on sales and David Corn
marketing again uh we really needed to
uh focus on
commercializing very quickly on our you
know enabling technology
long story short in 2020 we got acquired
actually the we got acquired on April
1st 2020 by Byron the data stock market
had crashed and the pandemic is Raising
we're very happy that you know uh by
that you know understood the value of
celsi and now are integrating uh you
know the cell C technology into variety
of you know product lines for buyered
so again you know just like with
handilab very similar kind of uh story
you know you less slightly different in
our start you know the company started
out with the actual business plan with a
desire to go into a certain area it was
able to leverage the business plan to
Garner not only you know a business plan
money but also Angel money and then we
focused on uh the circulating tumor cell
technology development for the next few
years
and then started generating lots of data
and then
um we we did run into you know uh
funding issues for funding that you know
CTC program so we had to Pivot the
company into you know microwave based
single cell uh you know analysis
application luckily we had uh you know
really a good IP that really allowed us
to keep focusing on the new new area
build in a momentum with with investors
and also you know uh able to get in a
commercial theme and then uh as we we uh
you know gathered attraction in the
market on the in the singers analysis we
eventually got acquired uh by bio red
so if I want to summarize the lessons
from cell C again you you need a theme
uh with with cell C you know mentoring
and nurturing young entrepreneurs can
create Great Unexpected results because
you know it the name of the game is
resource efficiency you want to get as
much as you get done and in this case we
had you know three young hungry uh
entrepreneurs that really wanted to
create a difference and that really
helped you know seed the company and its
plan without uh spending too much money
early on
the initial team's commitment and
passion really sets the Innovative
culture you know uh that's what really
builds the you know competitive
Advantage the technology that really
attracts you know dollar and other you
know folks to join the team but you do
need a commercial Focus team eventually
to grow and exit
you need lots of funding you know uh
startup Savvy and pragmatic investors
with Deep Pockets are needed to weather
the long road you know this is uh I'm
gonna take you know five to ten years
and then you you need the access to
Capital we're able to you know uh do
what you want me to do and then you know
the the pivot the changes are difficult
but very essential to get the right fit
of product market and channel again
that's the same team that emerged from
handilab you know you may be building
something very cool but you know the
market may not be right at the time so
getting that right you know being at the
right place at the right time is
important some people call it luck but I
think you it is if you're not in the
game understanding you will not see uh
you know the lock come by
and then you know most important thing
you know the right product you have to
build the right product solving an unmet
need that customers want to buy right
now uh I think that's important and in
the case of cell C the sales is
innovative patent estate in microfluidic
microwave single cell technology was the
key in its successful exit
so that's all on my talk uh now I would
be open to any questions that we might
have
well thank you very much Dr Han dick and
for that informative presentation and we
will now start the live q a portion of
this webinar if you have any questions
you want to ask please do so now just
click on that ask a question box located
on the far left of your screen so let's
get started we already have some great
questions coming in
our first question
says Dr khandik thank you for such an
enlightening story and of your
entrepreneurial Journey it amazes me in
both of your companies required a pivot
which must have been a gut-wrenching
decision business advisors often tell
you to stay focused on an area and not
to dig multiple holes yet say pivoting
was necessary for Success what is the
process Intuition or even criteria that
you use to make the decision to Pivot
and what advice would you give to those
who must pivot
okay so for you know I I'm coming from a
technology point of view you know when
you are creating a company you really
want to create more technology that you
and and compass into a particular
product so that you have options down
the road and then it's important
especially in this biotech space to
create more IEP at the beginning even
though you may not be taking it all the
way through you know the the development
process into a product
so I think it is very important to be
singularly focused at any one time on a
particular product and a particular
customer segment and you have to get
alignment of the entire team your board
the business advisors on the same
singular Focus but as a entrepreneur
leader you know you always have to keep
looking at the cues from the market if
the market is not buying means you are
not designing the right product or it's
not at the right time I think you have
to keep getting that feedback and then
as you I think you will sense it that
hey at some point if we are trying to
raise money on a particular concept for
a few years and haven't got it that's a
good enough feedback that hey you need
to change and at that point it's a it's
a difficult process of getting the whole
company aligned on the chains what the
changes and also the board and the
business advisors on the on the decision
to change it's a it's a difficult
process but if you if you get the data
to everybody that hey we've been trying
and this is not working out we need to
change I think it's it's it's important
to be able to do that I think you have
to be you know you have to do uh honest
job all along the way and very very
honest with with the feedback and also
with the board I think eventually you
can you can do it it's very difficult
but I think if if there is honesty on
all sides you are able to do that
you're muted Susie
I apologize thank you so much Dr handy
we have time for a couple more questions
how important would it be the location
for the biotech startup
yeah so you know uh for me both the
startups were in Ann Arbor Michigan you
know when we started handy lab in 2000
you know Ann Arbor was not known for you
know startup you know I think uh because
of the long time uh because we got the
money from local investors and we the
technology needed incubation for many
many years I think it was good that we
stayed in Ann Arbor because we were able
to grow the theme and grow together for
many many years and that was what
created tremendous you know you know
intellectual prowess for the team and I
think it helped us to stay in Ann Arbor
we had opportunities because of funding
to move to the Bay Area but it didn't
pan out so I think it was the right
thing for Handy lab and then over time
you know Ann Arbor morphed into a much
more entrepreneurial so you know selfie
was definitely the right spot to be in
Ann Arbor so I have some good viewpoints
I mean if you if you can you know I
think the location is important you have
to be in one of the startup hubs whether
it's you know the Bay Area or the East
Coast but you also have to be cognizant
of the fact that if you go to California
if your technology is really not very if
it's not you know enticing it is not
sexy enough you will it's hard to keep
your people intact because there is so
many opportun opportunities for talent
so you know in a if but in Ann Arbor I
don't think that mercenary attitude has
come to detect people yet so I think
it's a it depends on uh you know what
you want to uh you know accomplish if
you want to keep your the good people
intact for many many years maybe maybe
not you know California may not be the
best option unless you can really keep
them around
so the location is important but you
know it you need not be at at the East
or the west coast to really be
successful that's my whole point it
depends on you know exactly what stays
and what You Know Field of views you are
at
thank you so much Dr handican with time
for one more question what are you
currently working on at the at your
current job at biorad
okay so that's a a good question so
Barrett acquired cell C through the life
science division so after acquisition
actually I I I had an interest in going
back to the the clinical world because I
really uh
you know uh like the impact we can
create in the lives of people through
you know Innovations in clinical
Diagnostics so I actually moved to the
clinical diagnosis group of bioad and uh
Bharat has tremendous amount of you know
technology and PCR digital PCR and
variety of Cutting Edge molecular
techniques but it never had a focus from
a clinical side so I'm actually helping
you know innovate on a new platform for
you know molecular diagnostics for
biorad and then besides that I I get
involved with lots of You Know M A
activities to really grow the the
molecular business for buyer ad so you
know I'm building a small team in Ann
Arbor while working with my boss in
California to you know uh do whatever it
takes to build up that molecular
presence in diagnostics for biod
thank you so much and you know what we
have we actually have time for this um
last one that just came in is a
development agreement a key step in
getting acquired
um
no I mean you with you you could uh in
the case of Handy lab we did have a
development agreement with BD for
certain menu and then you know I think
that that accelerated to us being hanila
being acquired it could be one of the
steps but you know we with with the
second company you know selfie got in
getting acquired by that we never had
any development agreement but just you
know uh we went through a process where
you know the you know we we had many
companies look at cell C and then in
about that basically you know one out in
the end without any development
agreement
Dr handiq I want to thank you for your
presentation today would you like to
provide any final comments to our
audience before we go
no I think uh es one one comment I would
say that you know the the area of
Biotech uh especially bringing new
Innovations is very hard but it is
extremely important for this world we've
seen in the in the last two years you
know how you know Diagnostics have
really helped you know manage patients
better and I think the importance of
getting Diagnostics you know cutting as
Diagnostics uh is important you know
when when you look you know lose near
and dear ones it will hit home I think
you know we the researchers that's in
this space have to continually
continually innovate to get better and
better tools and you know tests into the
market because you will get you will get
a chance to impact this world
tremendously more than anything else
than in any other fields in this world
well I want to thank you again Dr handic
for your time and for your important
research and before we go I want to
thank our audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions
questions that we did not have time for
today and those submitted on demand
period will be addressed by our speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration and this
webcast can be viewed on demand until
for two years until May 18 2024
laboratory tool alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
event until next time take care everyone
bye-bye
thank you